alors justement les tue l'amour on s'est
dit bon c'est vrai que là on parle de
passion de rose d'amour mais il ya aussi
ce qu'on appelle le tue l'amour
françois viot vous alors vous vous
n'aimez pas les personnes qui parlent
pendant l'amour je vais faire marie
caroline
si tu nous regardes ce soir je peux te
dire que je n'ai jamais supporté que tu
fasses la commentatrice hippiques
pendant qu'on faisait l'amour je sais je
attendez quand même essayé pour moi elle
vous qu'est ce qu'elle disait que j'ai
commenté
voilà la course en tête à trois temps
comme trop longues heures de retard
est-ce que mâcher de temps en temps non
non non quand même pas mais ça ne te
tuer mais tous mes effets